[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday March 14th
you might be wondering why I'm wearing
these beads it's because I'm in Mobile
Alabama and I happen to walk past a
parade Hank I've been to Mobile Alabama
three times in my life and all three
times they've been having a parade Hank
I'm forced to conclude that either the
people of Mobile Alabama get really
excited whenever I come to town or else
they have a parade every day by the way
I wonder where all these great beads
came from oh yeah probably from those
shipping containers so Hank the reason
I'm in Mobile is that Sarah is curating
a show that's opening here called among
the ruins and it's great it includes all
these contemporary artists from all over
the world like this Japanese artist who
now lives in Queens who covered an
entire house in the Lower Ninth Ward of
New Orleans two years after the storm
with latex and cheese cloth and then
peeled it off so we have this like
ghostly remnant of the house or this
Chinese artist who cuts his profile out
of demolished buildings in Beijing or
these guys in Detroit who go to
abandoned buildings and paint them
Orange Hank my favorite thing about that
project in Detroit is that the color
they use to paint the houses Orange is a
Disney color called Tiger rific Orange
it's terrific
god I love ruins they're the rainbows of
the future Hank as much as I know you
love the Yeti I know it's probably not
going to be possible for you to come and
see this show in Mobile but maybe some
nerdfighters who live in Mobile will
have a chance to see it link in the
sidebar the other thing I absolutely
have to discuss today is the nerdfighter
blurbing book club barb barb barb blurb
that's right Hank it's time to announce
the winner of the first ever nerdfighter
warping book club can I have a drum roll
please
no no drum rolls are copyrighted okay no
drum roll the winner is marvelous ten
there's hell in this non-stop teen
Jubilee which amazingly enough is an
anagram of Maureen Johnson's 13 little
blue envelopes so the nerdfighter behind
that blurb will be receiving special
prizes although Hank I couldn't quite
find out who exactly that nerdfighter
was so hopefully you know Hank I also
have another announcement to make which
is that I have decided without
consulting you to declare a second
winner in the nerdfighting warming book
club that winner was the runner-up in
the vote whose blurb was I'm in you're
Europe's grievin my aunt kissing your
dudes in fact Hank I like that law book
blurb so much that I think I'm going to
declare that from now on
the nerdfighter boring book club will
have two contests one a regular blurbing
contest and one a law book contest so
for instance if we were reading Moby
Dick together and by the way I promise
you we will never have to read Moby Dick
together the winner might be I'm in your
oceans ponen your whales or if we were
reading Hamlet it might be like I'm in
your Denmark's feeling your Ophelia's
failing to make decisions so beginning
with the current book
slaughterhouse-five there will be two
competitions one for a regular blurb and
one for a law book blurb feel free to
submit both the deadline for the
slaughterhouse-five blurbs is going to
be wednesday at midnight and lastly Hank
I wanted to mention a couple of YouTube
shows I really like the first channel I
want to mention is called muse cast it's
a year-long conversation between five
friends trying to break into the
entertainment industry and the second is
the Australian vlogger frezz Ned who's
just brilliant all right Hank that's all
from me today I got to go back to
looking at ruins I'll see you at some
indeterminant point next week actually I
want to do just one more law book this
is exclusively for people who have read
one particular William Carlos Williams
poem got you some plums but I aided them
Kate thanks bye